[Music]
my name is tom
rago and i am the co-owner of rego
brothers shoe and leather repair
with my brother tony rigo and today i am
going to walk you through
a dog chewed louboutin shoe
approximate cost is eight hundred
dollars to one
thousand dollars when they came into us
the platform
was halfway chewed off the
top of the shoe wasn't there and the
heels were all chewed all had bite marks
on it
and you would think that this was an
unrepairable shoe
we are going to attempt to rebuild
the platform of the shoe the upper part
the black patent leather
and get the structure back to the shoe
to start out the process we are going to
give this to our repairman
ronnie who is going to put the shoe
together
we are using the heat gun to remove the
platform very carefully
trying to loosen the glue between the
shoe and the platform
[Music]
we now are putting the platform down on
the table
and taking a piece of bonded leather and
tracing out the platform
so that we can make a mold for the other
shoe
[Music]
what that involved is flipping the
platform over so it looked like a left
shoe instead of the right shoe
so we did that we took our measurements
[Music]
once we've got that pattern we now are
taking a hard piece of rubber
and we are shaping that with a dremel to
match
the other platform
the platform when you get it from
louboutin it's a
molded plastic base
molded plastic is not available to us so
we cut it
out of a very rigid piece of rubber
and we had to sand it to make the exact
curves
that it needed to have to fit the upper
part of the shoe
when you start with the upper part of
the shoe you take a flat piece of patent
leather
and you take the inside material which
is a bonded leather
that gives it the structure that gives
it the form
what we're doing now is we're heating up
the leather on the platform
so that we can stretch it make it more
malleable
so that it has no creases in it and then
we
pull it and attach it to the platform
[Music]
so now we have the top shape of the shoe
after we've gotten that we begin to form
it
to the platform underneath
[Music]
we have to mold that platform around the
top of the shoe and
that requires us using a hand dremel to
get the shape
of the platform to fit onto the upper
part of the shoe
that's just trial and error that you may
go through that several times
so now that we've repaired the upper
part of the shoe
we're going to take the platform and
attach the platform
to the upper part of the chute
now we are going to give the shoe to our
shoe repairman henry
so that he can attach the leather and
rubber sole
to the bottom of the shoe
now what we're doing is we're attaching
the red sole onto the bottom of the shoe
[Music]
we are going to take this shoe and we
are going to edge it
with black paint so that from the side
of the shoe
all you see is the black you won't see
any red
this shoe was really a challenge for us
and we think it came out
really great we think that when the
owner does get this shoe back
her mouth is gonna drop
[Music]
you